so we're looking at clips from trump's
coronavirus press briefing yesterday
we're doing it in short clips instead of
one big review
because i want to make sure that each of
these stories sort of gets its own
time because it was a really weird
press briefing so trump said completely
randomly
to a bloomberg to bloomberg reporter
mario parker
that he looks like michael bloomberg now
what's really odd about this is that
mario parker is black
and looks nothing like a nearly 80 year
old jewish man
named michael bloomberg take a look at
this clip bloomberg
you look like mr bloomberg go ahead
thank you mr president i think it's
important a temporary extension of
supplemental unemployment aid if uh the
deal that they're hashing that in
congress isn't completed by the end of
this week
what what does anybody make of this
tells tells the
i think this is the one black guy in the
room tells the one black guy
in the room you look like michael
bloomberg why
is this what donald trump thinks counts
as some kind of joke like is this humor
of some kind
is this meant to be clever i don't even
really get
what he's going for does trump think you
know one idea i had was
does trump think this is a way to signal
that you're not racist
like it you he's saying he's colorblind
in a sense you tell a black guy
he looks like a white guy i guess that
means that trump really is colorblind he
doesn't see color and he just sees
people as people
but it's crazy it doesn't make any sense
whatsoever
i was laughing uh someone tweeted me you
know david
this should have been a question on
trump's much famed cognitive test that
cognitive test that trump claims has 35
questions even though it has like 12
that trump says the last few questions
over very very difficult
questions that trump says neither joe
biden nor fox news host chris wallace
could successfully
uh could score as high as donald trump
did they should have put up
a picture of a black reporter and said
does this man look like michael
bloomberg and see if donald trump passes
the test
really really bizarre stuff and i don't
know if we
chalk this up to um or or consider
this a part of donald trump's
cognitive question marks is this trump
trying to be
funny is this i mean is it thinly veiled
racism of some kind like rather
i don't even understand this and i need
excuse me i need your help
actually trying to figure it out but
needless to say
the idea of bringing back these press
briefings kellyanne conway said i think
it was two weeks ago
the reason trump's approval is down is
he's no longer doing coronavirus press
briefings
and very shortly thereafter donald trump
decided to bring them back
the idea being it would help his
approval rating by next week we'll have
a sense of whether trump's approval
rating
is reversing course and improving uh
what seemed clear to me
early on was these press briefings were
actually the cause of low approval
ratings and you might remember that
the press briefings were abruptly
stopped when donald trump wondered aloud
about what about injecting isopropyl
alcohol or
bleach into the body as a sort of
cleaning
for coronavirus seems to me the problem
wasn't
uh that there there was an incredible
demand for press briefings
and after the break we are going to talk
about donald trump doubling down
in his support of a doctor who believes
hydroxychloroquine works to prevent
coronavirus or to treat coronavirus
who believes that if you have sex with a
demon
it can cause gynecological issues
who believes you don't need to wear a
mask who believes that there's already a
cure
for coronavirus and who believes that
there is a plan i hope you're sitting
down
to develop a vaccine that will make you
immune from becoming religious
okay that's after this short break make
sure you're following
me on instagram at david.pacman
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com pacman i've
been using privacy for a little over a
year now you've heard me talk about it
before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman